leles longues files de visiteurs
nene diminuent pas.
AÀ l'intérieur, un fascinant
vovoyage au Japon, en Thaïlande
etet ailleurs en Asie à travers
dedes siècles de représentations
cuculturelles, des croyances
etet de l'imaginaire.
LeLes interprétations de la peur
dede l'inconnu sont illustrées r
dedes peintures, des affiches
dede films, des bandes dessinées
mamanga et surtout, avec la pièe
mamaîtresse de l'exposition :
leles zombies des vivieux films
cacantonnais.
DeDes créatures fantastiques
ererrantes à la recherche du res
ététernel, très s loin de l'imae
acactuelle des zombies.
L'L'exposition  Enfer et fantôms
d'd'Asie  a été présentée à Pars
enen 2018 puis adaptée pour
lele public taïwanais...
..... afin d'inclure des élémens
dede la culture populaire
jajaponaise et cantonnaise,
mamais aussi du bouddhisme.
DeDes artistes locaux taïwanais
onont également une place de chx
dadans l'exposition.
L L'exposition s'annonçait déjà
popopulaire. Mais avant même
soson ouverture officielle,
dedes groupes religieux l'ont
dédénoncée, ce qui a aidé
àà sa popularité.
CeCertains ont même réclamé son
anannulation, craignant qu'elle
riridiculise les religions
ouou qu'elle mette en valeur
leles esprits errants.
" "Il s'agit simplement dee
sususciter une réflexion sur les
fafaçons d'imaginer et d'affronr
l'l'inconnu", répond-elle.
EnEn Asie, les fantômes ne meurt
jajamais et le public entretient
unune fascination pour la vie
apaprès la mort. Cettete exposin
lele confirme.
I ICI Philippe Leblanc,
R Radio-Canada, Tainan
d dans le sud de Taïwan.